These are the names in English,
the English translation of
George and George.
I believe Gog and Magog is an
English translation and a
biblical translation at that.
There are many descriptions
mentioned. about Gog and Magog.
Yeah, George and George. Now,
George and George are mentioned
twice in the Quran. They're
mentioned by name twice in the
Quran. First time is in the
second time in this in this
isolated verse here in
what we find of descriptions in
the Quran are the most relevant
descriptions of and those
descriptions are that yet
George are a wicked people
that's have an inclination to
murder and war and pillaging
and so forth. There are many,
many narrations regarding and
many. As a matter of fact, some
of these narrations have been
gathered
into independent
Priotes. There are narrations
which are agreed upon amongst
the scholars to be
fabrications. There are fab,
there are narrations which are
agreed upon amongst the
scholars to be weak. There are
fabrication, there are
narrations regarding that are
agreed upon amongst the
scholars to be authentic.
These authentic narrations give
us a couple of descriptions.
First of these descriptions is
that yet George and George are
human beings. Not monsters.
They are not beasts. Primitive
beasts. As other fabrications
would articulate.
Muslim, the prophet
mentions of their description
which we may conclude to only
mean that they are human beings
and they are descendants of
Adam Alaihi Salam. That can
evolve Second description that
we have of them that is
authentic Agreed upon amongst
the scholars, is that they are
extremely numerous. There are a
lot of them. So many, that they
are at the brink of being
innumerable. The third
description is the description
of their moral values and that
is that they are A people of
moral decadence.
They
are bloodthirsty. They are
prone to war and conflict, and
they have inclination to
violence as a means to
achieving their ends. There are
other narrations that are
mentioned that honestly, these
narrations due to the fact that
they are fabrications or
extremely weak or weak and
transmission they should not
have been translated honestly.
They should have been kept in
the books of scholars where
scholars and scholars alone may
look at them. However, they
have been translated.
by individuals who are good at
translating but not very good
at at deciphering what needs to
be translated from what need
not be. of these descriptions
is that yeah Jude are very
tiny, very very small. Some of
these narrations mention that.
They're so small.
they will look at a person's
shoe and mistake it for right
obviously a fabrication. They
have to be the ants essentially
Another
another description is of them
being very
very short, abnormally small.
by the foot or two feet or
three feet tall. Another
description is that they have
fangs for teeth or needles for
teeth. Other descriptions that
they have drills for tongues
etcetera. Excuse narrations are
all inauthentic. And if
you'll find that these
narrations usually root back to
the fables of the people of the
book.
Christians, and their
descriptions of yet Georgia
and and it is not unusual
books of history, or books of
that document murderous people
be extreme in their
descriptions. So, where do
these descriptions come from?
Historically, speaking, in when
we are dealing with history
that is not transmitted by
chain of narration as the
Muslims transmit there
narrations. Meaning, we have a
that chain of narration. We
know who they are and we are
positive that they are honest,
right? And not only that they
are honest but as well they are
are well versed and able to
memorize. This is a condition
for us to accept a narration
When we take away this factor
and we just have transmissions
of fables, we start to see a
very very pronounced divide
between reality and fantasy.
start to see fantasy bleeding
into reality
kind of how rumors are, right?
Everybody adds something, some
kind of emphasis in telling the
story that will later warp the
facts of that story. And this
is in everything, even modern,
even in modern times, we can
see this. We don't have that
vetting process that we refer
you as the chain of narration
or the chain of transmission
that the Muslims have been
endowed with then, we start to
see this, we start to see this
kind of fantastic descriptions
start to come out. So, for
instance, what I mean by this
is if we were to look at the
Persians and the Greeks, right?
or more specifically the
Persians and the
Spartans, for instance, they
had a very, very long history
and a very bloody history as
enemies, sworn enemies, the
Persians and the and the Romans
in Greek. They were sworn
enemies. When we look into the
ancient works of the Persians,
we'll see their descriptions of
the Greeks and Romans as being
barbaric and monstrous
a people that need to be
exterminated. When we look at
the descriptions of the Greeks,
of the Persians, their enemy.
They are described with things
having teeth. they eat
human flesh, and they are no
longer even human beings.
and this is because the human
being naturally when they
describe their enemy, they are
not usually going to describe
anything good about their
enemy. They're only going to
describe the negatives. And
these negatives are going to
become more and more pronounced
to the push thee
envelope of sanity with regards
to the description of enemies
over time Likewise, even in
modern times, if we look at the
French and the German,
France and Germany are historic
enemies. Even before Germany
was necessarily Germany, that
that people were sworn enemies
of the French. And likewise,
the depressions, they'll later
they formed an alliance with
the French for a common cause.
The point here is that when we
look at the descriptions of the
French, even in modern history,
even in history taught in
schools. If you look
at the description of Nazi
Germany We see descriptions
that make us question whether
the Germans were even human
beings, right? And that is
popular
today and I'm sure if we were
to examine what the Nazi
Germany was teaching about
France and America and Russia,
we would find similar
descriptions.
The point here is that these
fabrications have a very
organic nature and that is when
we remove the factor of chain
of narration, we remove the
factor of vetting every person
who narrates this narration.
Comparing this account to the
account of all of their other
peers and so on and so forth.
The vetting process of the
science of Hadith. When we
remove
that factor, we are left with
rumors and rumors are usually
So, this is where we will find
a lot of these descriptions of
Georgia. we have no reason
to believe that yet Georgia met
George,
are anything but human and very
likely yet Jude and are no
longer behind their wall. They
multiplied and they spread
throughout the earth as the
rest
human civilization has done and
the wall of that was built by
remains as an indicator for the
time of when they will descend
on mankind with violence
However, He is narrations and
these verses in do not
necessitate or say that yet
remain behind this wall till
today. Is it possible? Yes. Is
it possible that yeah are found
are in a place where we have
not discovered or in a place
where they are hidden from the
rest of mankind. Possible.
Probable? Not probable but
possible right? It is possible
We will not deny that and we
will not say for sure that is
not the case because that would
that would necessitate for us
to know for sure who yet Jude
are and we don't. However,
is it more probable that yet
Georgia are?
of these nations of human
beings that we see scattered
through the earth and that they
have they are a people of
modern technology yet they
retain their murderous nature.
Yes, and we see that in many of
the civilizations around today.
We will end with that.
Al